[Música]
bienvenidos al espacio de historia de
france 24 mi nombre es álvaro cordero el
salvador vive por estos días uno de los
momentos más violentos de los últimos
años el presidente en allí buque le ha
lanzado una polémica campaña de
represión contra los miembros de todas
las pandillas del país las conocidas
como maras que asolan con violencia a
esta nación desde hace décadas pero de
donde surgen estas organizaciones y por
qué el salvador no ha podido hasta ahora
con ellas para averiguarlo hay que
retroceder hasta 1980 en esa fecha
comenzó la guerra civil del salvador que
enfrentó durante 12 años al gobierno
apoyado por eeuu con la guerrilla del
frente farabundo martí para la
liberación nacional un conflicto marcado
por la extrema violencia que dejó más de
75.000 muertos y alrededor de 400.000
refugiados salvadoreños en eeuu es en
estas familias que huyeron de la guerra
donde está el origen de las maras
estos migrantes llegaron
mayoritariamente a la ciudad de los
ángeles en un ambiente hostil los
adolescentes de estas familias fueron
los primeros en unirse para protegerse
de otras pandillas urbanas la mayoría se
alistó en dos grupos el conocido como
barrio 18 de orígenes mexicanos pero que
aceptó a salvadoreños y la mara
salvatrucha 13 de esencia puramente
salvadoreña estos dos grupos en un
comienzo aliados empezaron a aumentar su
influencia en los barrios bajos de los
ángeles hasta que en un momento se
convirtieron en rivales las dos
pandillas se caracterizaron por su
extrema violencia su poder fue tal en
california que la solución que eeuu
planteó fue la extradición masiva de
estos pandilleros hacia el salvador a
mediados de la década de 1990 se estima
que unos cuatro mil fueron arrestados y
deportados una solución cortoplacista
que a la larga traería consecuencias
estos maderos llegaron a un país pobre
devastado por la guerra en donde había
familias rotas
el caldo de cultivo perfecto para seguir
creciendo estas maras se hicieron con el
control en las calles y comenzaron a
reclutar a miles de jóvenes provenientes
de familias pobres cuya única salida era
unirse a estas organizaciones que los
formaban desde adolescentes desde un
comienzo se exige a sus miembros
fidelidad absoluta a la mara y sólo se
entrena para cometer asesinatos
violaciones secuestros y extorsiones la
mayoría de ellos están marcados por todo
el cuerpo con tatuajes de la mar a la
que pertenecen y la traición se paga con
la muerte la rivalidad entre barrio 18 y
la mara salvatrucha 13 fue creciendo
hasta puntos insostenibles los
asesinatos diarios se multiplicaron en
el salvador durante los 90
estas organizaciones comenzaron a
controlar territorios donde el estado
salvadoreño no estaba hasta el punto de
tener presencia en el 94 por ciento de
los casi 300 municipios que conforman el
salvador
convertidas a muchas comunidades
en diversos puntos del país allí como en
impuestos de guerra
venden drogas
y rompen menores
asesinan y mantienen aterrorizados a
muchas familias bajo la presidencia de
francisco flores entre 1999 y 2004 se
empezó a recurrir a la táctica de la
mano dura frenar violencia con más
violencia el estado comenzó una campaña
de detenciones masivas en las que
también hubo asesinatos a mareros una
política muy cuestionada que además
terminó con la vida de cientos de
civiles que fueron confundidos con
pandilleros o simplemente se vieron en
fuego cruzado y que además nos sirvió
para poner fin a las maras de hecho su
poder aumentó desde las cárceles donde
pudieron organizarse ya que normalmente
tenían penales exclusivos para cada
pandilla este contexto hizo que en 2012
el gobierno buscará una tregua a cambio
de beneficios carcelarios algo que fue
muy impopular en la población a pesar de
que los asesinatos se redujeron a la
mitad entre ese año y 2014 sin embargo
el final de la tregua en 2015 convirtió
a el salvador en el país más peligroso
del mundo al alcanzarse la cifra de 105
homicidios por cada 100.000 habitantes
una situación dramática
a miles de salvadoreños a huir del país
por miedo irónicamente las maras que se
formaron en los 80 en eeuu y que fueron
expulsadas por su violencia generaron
una crisis migratoria 30 años después
que afectó de lleno a eeuu es en este
contexto en el que aparece la figura del
presidente en allí bukele en el año 2019
una de sus principales promesas fue
terminar con la violencia de las
pandillas y así fue durante sus primeros
años de mandato las tasas de homicidios
bajaron de los 105 a los 20 por cada
100.000 habitantes la cuestión es que
esto parecía responder a un acuerdo
secreto con las maras a cambio de
beneficios algo que el estado siempre
negó pero que en medios de comunicación
locales como el faro e incluso eeuu
confirmaron por lo que el aumento de
asesinatos en los últimos días y la
draconiana reacción de bucle que decretó
el estado de excepción y ordenó
encarcelar a miles de pandilleros y
racionar la alimentación de los presos
parecen responder a una ruptura de esos
acuerdos
desde el domingo la comida es racionada
y los 16.000 pandilleros encarcelados no
han salido de sus celdas ni han visto el
sol en estos días hemos arrestado tres
mil más y seguimos así que cada vez
habrá menos espacio y tendremos que
reaccionar aún más buque le vuelve a
tácticas que sus antecesores ya
utilizaron y que se demostró que no
sirvieron de mucho ante un problema que
es difícil de solucionar con más
violencia especialmente porque el poder
estructural que tienen estas maras
existe gracias a la profunda desigualdad
y pobreza que sufre el salvador desde
hace décadas con esto concluimos gracias
por compartir y comentar estas historias
que las encuentran en los programas de
france 24 punto com
[Música]